[Musica]
ma chi cazzo
oggi non so perché c'ho voglia di fare
cose a casa dopo il giorno di pausa è
andata è andata di merda ciao sera
adesso state tutti aspettando che io
metta la intro di john cena ma non la
metterò perché sono trasgressiva st
l'ultima giusto per cosa appena successo
cosa
insegno zio fabi a guidare prima cosa si
tiene la testa fuori dal parabrezza e
poi tutto il culo fuori da parabrezza e
questo è il modo più sicuro per guidare
ragazzi poi si esplode da ragazzi per i
2 milioni ad occhi chiusi a caso
[Musica]
la mia testa è libera
è uno sport questo stare sulla palla con
le ginocchia
mi piace e bellezza ecco la madonna
questo invece era da 10
gli anni fa la vittoria come si deve vai
così
che superman sarà vivo io io cargo
successo quindi a modo mio è che me lo
smoking cheyenne amiche tipo michael
jackson che si piega in avanti
bellissimo col cazzo duro che ho anche
mancavano arriva sicura da sola ma veri
a questa ma [ __ ]
hai mai notato che ostuni a sei lettere
un multiplo di tre che ricorda vagamente
le punte di un triangolo illuminati con
ford ragazzi mi avete meno fatto che
l'occhio degli illuminati e circolare
proprio come la lettera o di ostuni
david hockney renderle papa non ci
arriva ma proviamoci ragazzi non so che
restano senza beccano qui non possiamo
andare così corde ma chi ha detto no no
io ti amo io ti amo non puoi mollarmi
così cazzo come faccio la giornata dai
che ce la posso fare ciò posso partiti
su no lou reed a puntare ha mai tradito
la vj non può farlo cosa sei serio
zio non mi conosce anche tu mi sarà lo
dico ok agli addominali e di aldo milani
lo so che ce l'hai
questo è un inchino ma non me ne frega
un cazzo degli inchini mattone per cento
questo è quel adrenalina volevo oggi ma
inizia che gioco di merda
cosa fai nonno cosa sta facendo
a del ritmo questa cosa è un livello che
trasuda pro argine 5 stelle zio
complimenti proprio mi ha cambiato la
giornata da così a così cos'è ragazzi in
transformers temi
cos'è sta roba di che cos'è ginnaste
vite parallele
[Musica]
sei in occa coloni punti dito cosi ma
ripensandoci seguiti regalo anche un
anello tanto ti sta bene sul dito perché
la mia testa sta continuando a girare a
caso ragazzi ci di un cena che parte
incredibile lo prende se lo in groppa il
cazzo di salto era questo
[Musica]
ma dai già fi buttarti almeno giu almeno
giu di una nervosa giù giù finale di
champions league manchester united
contro la parrocchia di frattamaggiore
cioè possiamo fare ragazzi ha vinto
frattamaggiore
ci sono donne nude in questo livello
spiegatemi il senso ma dove le vedono
nuda sentite non è che perfetto così va
me perché non ha senso se no cosa sto
pensando di llull alta voce che bello
che tu stai in silenzio io sto guardarti
potremmo passare per dei due ed
efficienti gup dogma cosa non rende
tanto vero mi fa strano
ok sono stato ucciso da un pacco di
patatine cosa fa ma cos'è ma cos'era
[Musica]
cos'è oh mio dio ma dove vai
komen sonate in gra farmi steam
[Musica]
arrivato alla porta e difficile ma ci
provo
vabbè l'importante è partecipare
gillet il meglio di un nonno che cos'è
lo stack o no vabbè aveva degli spasmi
sto ragazzo
[Musica]
in verità e perché ti amo stimati ucciso
perché ti amo e io lo so che ho
sbagliato ma ha la tizia un pene
spuntato e siamo su è più il life
eccolo nel pene diretto questo sport
you can't io clark kent madonna che
pessima anche questa squadra che le
gambe annuncio perché comunque che
continuano a sculettare nonostante siano
staccate proprio dal nonno loro sculetta
[Musica]
se la potrò fare io continuerò così
porca di quella che girano le palle non
mi fa incazzare suo livello sono io che
sono un po che cazzo succede
tu non puoi passare bastardo voi non lo
sapete ma i ratei cavalli sono persone
cattive ma veramente cattive soprattutto
questo molto cattivo inutile che fai tu
tu perché non stai ascoltando un cazzo
ora kakà dio mio no lì perché non pensa
bene anche nelle situazioni di morte o
yo yo yo yo yo ma lavori una spalla di
diamante nel è il cazzo guardi così sono
entrato sono entrato sono entrato non
sono entrato non solo fa vince ai
ragazzi diciamo che parata brutta
insieme
[Musica]